- I love you, you're so sweet.
This is horrible to do to
a person who loves animals.
I do not need more animals, oh my God,
but they're so adorable.
If y'all get these puppies and
you separate these sisters,
I will haunt you when I'm dead.
(upbeat music)
Hey, what's up y'all, I'm
Kelly Clarkson and I am hanging
out with puppies while
answering y'alls questions,
so it's basically the best afternoon ever.
Okay, here we go, let's start.
You want it, you want this one.
(laughing)
Blake Shelton, Adam
Levine, or Alicia Keys?
Oh, it depends on the scenario.
I mean I think I'd call Blake,
we've, I know him a little
better than the others, but
I don't know, I feel like
Adam could charm my
way out of a situation.
And Alicia Keys has this
weird gravitational pull
to like humans, so she
could help me out, too.
I don't know, people fall
for the southern charm.
I'd probably call Blake,
I'd probably call him.
Toni Braxton, Bonnie Raitt,
Michele Obama, Mariah Carey,
it's so weird that you say
this because I did get a
handwritten letter from
Michelle Obama about Go High,
which I obviously wrote
inspired by the message,
you know, she gave at the
Democratic Convention.
That's how I said it to her,
the Democratic Convention,
and they like to tickle your toes.
Okay, let's um, he likes my rainbow nails.
You've gotta stop ticklin' my toes.
(laughter)
Simon Cowell, Paula
Abdul, or Justin Guarini?
I like a person that can discipline,
so I'm probably gonna pick Simon.
And he has a kiddo now, so he knows how to
lay down the law.
Watch him actually be a
softie with kids, though.
Hey, you wanna play?
Wa do do do do do do do.
That's hard.
I actually really dig Pocahontas,
the voice of Pocahontas.
I think her voice is amazing.
She was just rad, you know
what I feel like a lot of the
princesses are like damsels
and she was like "I got this
John Smith, follow me."
Like, I love her.
My daughter loves Pocahontas, too.
(laughing)
Tickle.
You like pantyhose, my man, ow.
Um, I get, I'm getting attacked.
No, no (laughing)
I guess I'd say, I don't
really get nervous so it's been
kind of a thing to help
people with nervous energy.
I don't actually know that
I'm helpful 'cause I'm like,
just get over it, you
might suck, you might
do great, you know?
But probably just how to really
be a coach and, you know,
instead of me just doing
I have to kinda help
like mold and teach.
They're everywhere, I love it.
I mean, does he love me or what?
Like he has not left me.
I love you.
Here, let me answer another one.
Do you wanna help me?
Oh, I'd cry of happiness (laughter)
Oh god, wait, no no no.
I don't know, I guess I'd
grab a glass of wine, y'all.
That's not, that's few
and far between, we have
four kids, so, and oh (laughter)
Oh my gosh, okay, so
Well, no one answered, so (laughter)
No one answered my call, so.
I didn't actually call them,
I just put it on Twitter,
'cause I didn't want it
to be awkward if they
didn't wanna do it.
So, but I did it with a song
that actually ended up on
my album, Piece By Piece, and
it's called Dance With Me.
♪ Come on and dance with me ♪
It's like this like Bowie, kind
of Abba vibe, and I love it.
And, like literally, you're
so beautiful and you will not
leave me, I love him.
Anything from the Harry
Styles album, I love it.
Or Evolve Imagine Dragons,
'cause that's good.
I love both those albums
right now, they're pretty rad.
Or Kourtney B, 'cause I just
think it'd be fun to watch
me sing like Red Bottom Shoes.
I just, it would be bad.
Red Bottom Heels?
No wait, did I say it wrong?
See, already I'm not, it's not a fit.
I've grown up listening
to so many of your songs,
Ooo, my favorite old school
song like from the beginning
is Miss Independence still.
Live it's so much better than on record.
My favorite new song ever
to perform, like above all,
is Whole Lotta Woman off this
new album Meaning of Life.
It is, it gives me life on so many levels.
Oh my God, on my, I can't.
This is the worst situation for me.
I'm gonna buy all these
dogs or take 'em home.
(laughter)
It was at a show, and a girl
threw me her bra, and it
was supposed to be funny,
like we support you, get it?
But, I was like, this is
not an Aerosmith concert.
This is a Kelly Clarkson
concert, like, but if was funny.
So points for being clever.
I would have a beer with you.
I would have some wine with you.
I don't really enjoy beer too much.
Ooo, I'd probably pick
who I said earlier that I
wanted to sing, I'd probably
pick P!nk, and Jessie J.
I mean God, I love so many,
Adele, Alicia Keys, like I'd
pick a bunch of just like soulful singers.
There's a lot of women I love.
Demi, I love Demi.
How did you feel about that?
- No, Kelly Clarkson!
- It was awesome.
You know why it was awesome?
Because he was actually really cool.
Sometimes you meet people
and that doesn't happen.
Exactly.
They know what I'm talkin' about, exactly.
That's what you wanna do to 'em.
Okay, one more.
I never, never voted on my
season, not even for myself.
Which is dumb, like I should've.
But, somebody does.
You need love.
You need this love.
And like why would you not
want this, look at this,
this is loyalty.
You're just like, it's story time.
Oh, your eyes.
I'm getting sucked into the
vortex, my husband will kill me.
Y'all so if you want any of
'em come on, they're so cute,
we got Leo, Thelma and
Louise, got Copper, and look
they want a home, they need a home.
And you can do it.
Puppies are so much cooler than humans.
Like, come on.
Alright, so if you want one
of 'em y'all gotta look up
You gotta find 'em, you gotta
make a little friend for life.
And don't separate the sisters, please.
Come on, get Thelma and Louise together.
They could be buddies.
What!
He is takin' it down.
I love these dogs.